breath [ __ ] gonna get it black gonna
get it what's goin on what's goin on
what's goin on what's goin on what's
goin on what's goin on what's goin on
that's the question that Larry Gopnik
the ill-fated protagonist of the Coen
brothers dark comedy a serious man keeps
asking it's a reflexive and sort of
stupid question one in response to a
series of unfortunate events that seem
to be tearing Larry's quiet contented
suburban life apart without cause first
his wife demands a divorce then his
student tries to blackmail him for a
passing grade then his neighbor
infringes on his property then his
wife's lover dies and he's forced to pay
for it then his brother gets in trouble
with the law and he has to pay for that
too then his chance at tenure is
threatened by anonymous hate mail he
also gets into a car accident witnesses
the death of his lawyer and is forced to
pay for a record subscription even
though I didn't do anything being a Coen
Brothers movie each of these situations
compound and unfold into one another
with surgical precision and they are
each individually illustrative of their
own batch of themes which taken together
sort of shape out the central message of
the movie like one of those optical
illusions that demonstrate closure of
course there is no real closure in a
serious man just as there's not really a
shape in the illusion that doesn't stop
Larry from seeking it though he wants to
understand what he's done to deserve
such misfortune seemingly unaware of
what the audience could see clear as day
that it's Larry's inaction his constant
refrain of having done anything that
causes so many of his problems Larry
knows the actions have consequences but
inaction has consequences
- instead of grappling with this fact
Larry looks for a way to interpret his
suffering seeking out the Council of
three rabbis the first a junior rabbi
lectures Larry on the importance of
perspective that's what it is Larry the
second tells a convoluted parable about
a dentist who finds a message in a
patient's teeth that never resolves
itself illustrating the inscrutability
of God's
plan and the third rabbi he elderly wise
rabbi Marshak refuses to see him
altogether literal izing the heavenly
silence in the face of big questions
that prompted Larry search for advice in
the first place a lot of the things that
Larry hears are cliches like the need to
change your perspective look at the
parking lot Larry and yet many of them
are true of course cliche and parable
are two devices that people use to
understand what's going on and they're
not the only that a serious man has to
offer
Larry's son Danny uses music and drugs
so does their next-door neighbor mrs.
Sam ski Larry's brother uses a complex
probability map of the universe called
the mint Acula s-- and Larry himself
teaches the theories of physics and
mathematics namely an equation that
seems to definitively prove the
underwriting uncertainty of all things I
can see that it's subtle clever but at
the end of the day is it convincing at
its core this film questions the
persuasiveness of every interpretive
device by placing them side by side and
showing how they fail to work together
and form any kind of semblance of
coherence the Cohens communicate the
real dread of a world that's become
unreadable and they take this failure
down to the most basic form of
interpretation the use of language a lot
of attention is paid to the language of
Heber an ancient language that's lost
much of its force in the modern world
indeed even in the 1960s young danny
Gopnik was doing exactly what I did when
faced with the Torah portion to learn
from my bar mitzvah he had vinyls I had
tapes but neither of us learned to read
or understand the Hebrew instead we
memorized the sounds that to us remain
gibberish Tibet no no Elmo sure Danny
can't find his place when the time comes
because those symbols are as
incomprehensible as the mint Acula tsa's
and even in English several times in the
film people are asked to repeat things
or just hear them as nonsense yes mi see
dear sir my sir Mia some eyes if so
interpretation is how we nail down the
world around us word by word fable by
fable equation by equation we secure the
storm of experience on two fixed points
and when these start to come undone and
unforeseen circumstances are always
threatening to do that it can be very
traumatic
we like Lowry reach for anything that
can orient us explains the appeal of
religion yet the serious man documents
its ever decreasing usefulness in the
modern age of course this criticism of
interpretive methods ought to make us
realize that we're watching a form of
interpretation the cinematic narrative a
serious man a film in which every
element is ambiguous in which cause and
effect the engine of any narrative is
willfully disregarded suggest that film
and story are plagued by the same
problems as all the other devices
despite what Hollywood would have you
believe one of the most confounding
things about the film is its opening
prologue a short fable filmed in a
different aspect ratio' about a Jewish
couple in the old country who stabbed
and maybe kill either a good Samaritan
or a demon the prologues meaning and its
relationship to the rest of the film are
totally nebulous there's just enough
thumb attic similarity to prompt
interpretation but once you try the only
outcome can be frustration moving the
viewer into a headspace like that is
neither pretentious nor unwieldy it's
the effect of a subtle experienced and
masterful craftsmanship the Coen
brothers have been doing this for years
we just don't understand what a serious
man is their most explicit account of a
bleak but unflinching philosophy I don't
understand one that remains skeptical
about the things we believe film story
and interpretation can do it understands
that the big philosophical truths about
human life
are devastatingly simple there is no God
there is no objective or cosmic purpose
for us people experience joy to varying
degrees but everybody suffers anyone can
figure these things out with a small
amount of observation introspection and
study and once you do that dim feeling
of disappointment will always be there
but there should also be relief the kind
of relief you can only get when putting
aside questions that are really a waste
of time because only when the reflexive
and sort of stupid questions are dropped
in the better questions be asked better
questions like whether or not the mind
hey everybody thanks for watching if you
want to see more film analyses like
these click here and pledge my patreon
page a as little as one dollar per video
anything helps that's what keeps this
channel alive I do this full-time and I
really need your help to keep it going I
want to do a lot more of these and
painting analyses poem analysis book
music everything like that and if you
want to see more before you decide to
pledge you can click right here there is
a playlist of all the understanding art
series I've done so far so thank you so
much and I will see you next Wednesday